our group did a really interesting study
of this um we we brought people into the
lab and and in this experiment one
sample were police officers and one
sample were probation officers found the
same thing in each sample so we bring
them into the lab and we say we're gonna
ask you to read through this
hypothetical discussion of a crime and
and the person is given it is going to
be given a couple paragraphs to read
that describe a crime but don't have any
information about the perpetrators race
in each case it's a juvenile now we tell
you that before you read this we want
you to do an exercise to kind of clear
your mind and we ask you to look at a
computer and to tell us whether a point
of light that you're in see flashing is
on the right side or the left side of
the screen now in reality it's not a
point of light it's a word but it's
flashed so quickly that you can't
process it it's all subliminal half the
people in the study get a list of words
that we associate with African Americans
things like Oprah or reggae so not bad
things but things that we tend to
associate with being black half the
sample gets a list of words that has no
racial
association but that are matched for
their word length and then people are
given these crimes to read and they're
asked how guilty is the person how much
punishment does the person deserve how
likely is the person to reoffended ulta
is this offender and in both samples
regardless of the race of the person in
the experiment if you got primed to
think of African Americans you rated the
person the criminal as guilty er more
deserving of punishment more likely to
reoffend more adult-like
alright and this happened as I said
regardless of the race of the person in
the experiment so so black police
officers were just as likely to do this
as white police officers black probation
officers just as likely as white
probation officers but it gets to
something that's important about
understanding disproportionate minority
involvement in the system which is that
we have unconscious biases that affect
the decisions that we make
well racial disproportionality in the
justice system is seen it at virtually
every level that you look at so it's
seen in terms of who gets arrested it's
seen in terms of how people are charged
it's seen in terms of who gets detained
it's seen in terms of who gets
incarcerated and it's seen in terms of
who gets transferred and all of those
levels of involvement in the system you
see more black and Latino kids than you
do white kids controlling for their
criminal behavior um there isn't one
thing that causes this to happen it's I
think probably the some of many smaller
things but then when added up have a
large effect so we know that there is
racial profiling going on in terms of
how law ordains work we know that people
have unconscious biases against kids of
color that might lead them to to see
them as more dangerous when they may not
be you you tend to see
disproportionality the most that less
serious crime so just in in a concrete
way if you're talking about somebody
who's murdered somebody
it really doesn't matter for the most
part whether that criminal is black or
white they're going to be punished for
murder but if you're talking about
somebody who's arrested for drug dealing
you know there's a lot of subjectivity
that goes on in how the charge is made
and in what the outcome of the charge is
um it's been it's been done in a couple
of places and and and and and been
effective so what we so what you can do
is you can give the decision-makers
objective criteria by which to decide
how to punish or sanction somebody and
those objective criteria could include
things like the grades somebody was
getting in school the person's prior
record the person's behavior while in
the detention facility whether how the
person scored on some test of
personality or aggression or whatever
but when those kinds of objective
scoring systems are implemented that
then tell you well given this score we
want to use this sanction you can
eliminate the the the racial differences
in the way kids are treated